North Korea is perhaps the most emetic
closed off and isolated country on the
planet.
I can you that now in 2018 it seems to
be living in 1960
hello
the now this entire store,
it might be about to change here and
there's your politic.
We've already talked about how
capitalism is reaching North Korea by
following popular markets.
How can entire entrepreneurial
revolution is taking place and how
today,
well then at 50% of North Koreans to
make a living from the private economy.
However,
a couple of questions remains on the
table.
What does one of the most totalitarian
governments on the planet think about
this particular capitalist revolution?
What are his plans and other very,
very important question.
Who the hell would be willing to invest
in North Korea?
Well,
listen up.
Okay.
Views aren't the best of times.
On June the 12th 2018 historic in
meeting was held in Singapore for the
first time.
TheU s presidents in this case,
Donald Trump mess within North Korea.
Why?
Well,
supposedly this was to d nuclearized
North Korea.
Yeah.
The actual goal.
Well in addition seem taking a couple of
pictures.
I mean,
hey,
pictures never hurts because the idea
was to start a dialogue and cool down
the enormous tension that had been
growing between the two countries and
for North Korea from continuing with a
nuclear program that could have given it
the ability to attack even the United
States.
Well hold on a minute because you know,
one the things theory and another thing
is truth.
I mean,
check out the latest news.
Okay.
West spy agencies,
North Korea is now working on new
missile secretary of state.
Mike Palm Peo acknowledged during Senate
testimony that North Korea factories
continue to produce facade material used
in making nuclear weapons.
And nowadays as we told you,
you hear on visual politic,
it seems very difficult for the
Pyongyang regime to agree at least in
the short term,
to get rid of its nuclear weapons,
which are after all of that best life
insurance.
But of course that doesn't mean they
won't accept to making concessions to
normalize their relations with the rest
of the welds and ends the international
sanctions.
Because you see since Kim Jong Un came
to power in 2011 he said two priorities
on the one hand develop a nuclear bomb
and on the other something far less
sinister reforming the economy.
Yes,
you heard that right.
Although it seems hard to believe one of
the objectives that Kim Jong own vet
North Korean dictator has set himself is
to change his country's bad economic
situation by copying or some of the
changes that have taken place in
countries like China and Vietnam this
out.
Once they develop their nuclear
capabilities Pyongyang's number one
priority is precisely this to advance in
economic development.
Of course to achieve this they need to
end international sanctions which are
causing enormous damage.
Yes,
we'll see how that,
it may seem hard to believe North Korea
situation could get even worse.
For example,
between the sanctions and the sinking of
Venezuela,
one of the few countries that had
aligned itself with North Korea
relations.
You have collapsed,
but of course when we talk about North
Korea in the economy,
we need to talk about China.
80% of all North Korean trade and
foreign exchange occurs here and once
that happened is that China has been
pushing Pyongyang for years to get some
reforms going once and for all.
And since those changes have been slower
than a total with rheumatism,
well last year Beijing decided to start
applying international sanctions.
This is what was happening in August of
2017 China to implement UN sanctions on
North Korea trying to band North Korean
iron lead and coal imports as part of UN
sanctions.
As you can imagine,
considering the enormous dependence that
North Korea has on China,
this has been a disaster.
Just in the first six months of 2018
Chinese purchases of North Korean
products have plummeted by more than 90%
of Chinese exports to North Korea by 40%
this of course is in the official market
and as we've seen,
there is a parallel market,
the black market,
and that's an entirely different story.
The fact is that all this has led North
Korea and industrial and mining
production to go through its worst time
in recent years as if we had the
disastrous state of the country's
infrastructure to all of this with our
continuous black,
less than a thousand kilometers of paved
roads throughout the country and to get
to crap.
It trains that in many cases,
don't go over 20 kilometers or 12 miles
per hour.
It's clear that this country urgently
needs a 180 degree turn,
and you know what's,
they also know that in Pyongyang.
Okay,
Ken,
North Korea become the new Vietnam.
In 1986 Vietnam launched the well known
Dorothy Moye policy,
a set of economic reforms similar to
those of den Shao Ping and China.
These had the mission of setting
communism aside.
In order to jumpstart a market economy
to achieve this,
agricultural cooperatives were
dissolved.
Price controls were eliminated,
land ownership was allowed,
and policies were put in place to
attract foreign investment.
So what was the result of all of this?
While over the following 30 years,
Vietnam economy grew at an average
annual rate of almost 7% today,
Vietnam is transforming at a break,
neck speed and its exports are or any
larger than those of countries like
Brazil or Australia.
Well,
at the last into Korean summit in April
between Kim Jong Un's the president of
South Korea Moon Gin,
the North Korean leader expressed an
interest in following the model of
Vietnam and following this line,
the North Korean government has approved
some significant measures in recent
years,
for example,
and it has promoted the creation of
private markets has given more autonomy
to public companies.
It does granted land parcels to peasants
for private exploitation.
However,
despite all of this,
there are two questions which we need to
answer.
He won't.
Earth would be willing to invest in
North Korea and what else is the
Pyongyang government willing to do?
I'll listen up.
Would invest in North Korea.
If you were asked which countries you
would like to do business in,
North Korea would probably be one of
your last options.
Investing in such a totalitarian comes
from where the leader makes and unmixed
laws.
At will where the government Daggett's
with brutality and dedicates itself to
threatening the rest of the planet.
Investing in a country where the rule of
law and legal security is pure fantasy.
I mean,
come on while folks,
the truth is they're not everyone sees
it this way.
Okay.
See some of South Korea is the largest
company is such as high on dye lot
cooperation and Samsung have already set
up work groups to investigate and
analyze the potential business
opportunities in North Korea and
according to polls,
three quarters of South Korean companies
would be willing to do business in North
Korea if sanctions were lifted high on
day,
for example,
is already preparing an early reopening
of the industrial case on zone and
industrial saying next to the border of
South Korea.
That was created in 2004 to how's
foreign companies,
mainly South Korea,
which employs more than 80,000
North Koreans.
But in 2013 given the growing tensions
between the two careers,
it was closed by the Pyongyang
government.
Even recently,
Jim Rogers,
one of the most important and well known
investors of all time has lamented the
fact that the United States doesn't
allow him to invest in North Korea and
just made statements such as these
Korea is now going to be the most
exciting country in the world.
Kim Jong Goon does not want war.
Kim is not North Korean.
He was educated in Switzerland.
He knows there's a different world out
there.
They need everything electricity,
so tablecloths,
if you've got any kind of expertise,
you're going to make a fortune.
Jim Rogers,
but the holy Roman just amendment.
The question we have to ask ourselves
is,
well,
what the hell do they see in a country
like North Korea?
Well,
fundamentally they see opportunities.
North Korea has a very young,
and it's very entrepreneurial population
with low labor costs.
In addition,
the country,
it seems to be quite rich and net for
resources.
It's got gold,
zinc,
copper,
and rare earth elements.
The estimate of value of all of these
minerals could be more than $6 billion.
As Jim Rogers says,
the country is still being built.
It needs everything.
And if that wasn't enough.
It's also located between two economic
powers,
China and South Korea.
You see it the last Inter Korean summit,
it's the South Korean president gave Kim
Jong a pen drive that included lots of
the investments that South Korea we'd be
willing to.
Yeah.
Do you know what investments would be
included on this 10 drive?
Well sold.
We'll be very interested in building
trends,
Korean railroads that in addition to
boosting the North Korean economy would
allow South Korea to export goods much
more quickly to China.
And it's the same story with roads,
all pipelines,
et cetera.
These would be billion dollar plans.
Of course not everything is so simple
and enthusiasm is far from widespread.
North Korea is a brutal dictatorship.
Corruption is huge and the government
can do literally whatever it wants.
For example,
it can expropriate.
[inaudible]
is where the money is to be made.
If you can figure out how to not get
expropriated,
Justin Hastings and associate professor
at the University of Sydney,
and then of course there's the issue of
international sanctions as a consequence
of their nuclear program and until those
are lifted any change,
it's going to have a very short run.
Now it's precisely at this point that
China can play a very important role.
You See,
Xi Jinping has managed to do what
China's been planning for years,
getting Qian Yang going,
which could obviously mean a lot of big
business with Chinese companies.
That's why we now see headlines like
this.
China suggests sanctions relief for
North Korea after trump Kim summit,
and not only that,
China has allowed the black markets
between both countries to flourish.
It's accelerated the development plans
in the border area and is already
studying the eminence opening of special
economic zones on the North Korean
border and then there's tourism,
which is one of Kim Jong Un's
governments.
Greatest priorities.
Listen Up,
right?
Korea.
A holiday spot was the arrival of
Chinese tourists has continued in recent
years and since May,
2018 the number of daily arrivals is
more than doubled.
You're going to run at least seven or
eight tour routes to North Korea this
year,
including a one day tour to nano and a
trip of four to five days to Pyongyang.
K Song and Pawn Joan changing it.
Deputy manager of a Chinese travel
company.
Well,
tourism is precisely one of the
Pyongyang government's top priorities
for several reasons.
First,
it generates employment.
Remember,
this is a very labor intensive Saxa.
It also attracts investments that helps
obtain foreign currency very quick.
Okay.
On the other
hand,
tourism could change the regimes image
and the truth is that swapping nuclear
parades and nuclear threats with exotic
beaches and seaside dinners,
it's going to be good for business.
Do you do this?
In 2014 the Korean government created
these special tourist of one son,
a special economic zone where foreign
investment is allowed and where in
principle the regime would allow more
freedom for developing tourism.
Yes,
this is the same area where until
recently the army did things like this.
You know,
North Korea and things is that with the
nuclear program and the sanctions
results have been very scarce.
However,
Kim Jong Un,
he wants to step on the gas without
going any further.
In 2017 the North Korean governments and
to delegation to Spain,
which is one of the major tourist powers
of the world in order to check out
places and like panadol more marina
d'or.
The idea was that this delegation would
learn from them and get some ideas.
Apparently Pyongyang's goal is to
attract more than 1 million tourists per
year in the short term and five to 10
million more in the foreseeable future.
The question is,
will Kim Jong really be willing to carry
out all of the reforms that the country
needs to get these plans to come to
life?
Well,
folks,
only the future going to be able to
answer that question for now.
What seems clear is that we have the
best opportunity to leave the North
Korean nightmare behind,
which isn't only a threat to the rest of
the world's best.
Above all,
it's a punishments and to great prison
of fear and repression for the North
Koreans themselves.
But now it's your turn.
Are you in favor of lifting sanctions
against North Korea?
While leave your answer in the comments
below,
as well as in this survey,
and I really hope you enjoyed this
video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did.
And don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos and also don't forget to
check it off.
Friends of the reconsider media podcast,
they provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine.
And also of course,
this challenge is made possible because
of our Patrion as our patrons on that
platform.
Please do consider joining them and
helping us in our mission of providing
independent political coverage.
And as always,
thanks for watching.